no reasonable person can be happy about
the state of the country right now there
is disorder on every front the economy
is in shambles inflation is at record
highs we can't get basic goods like baby
formula there have been horrific spikes
in violence and the world order is
cracking and to top it all off energy
costs are through the roof it is
difficult to understand how political
leaders could screw up
so
perfectly
on every single front
until you realize
that the present misery is not a bug but
rather a feature of the ruling classes
program here is joe biden's explanation
when it comes to the gas prices
uh we're going through an incredible
transition
that is taking place that god willing
when it's over we'll be stronger and the
world will be stronger and less relying
on fossil fuels
when this is over there it is that's why
that's why gas prices are high because
of the incredible transition that biden
is encouraging
a transition from one way of life to
another apparently with the approval of
our rulers this was the plan
all along and you can see it most
clearly when it comes to energy
every normal person is upset about
energy prices people are struggling to
fill their tanks heat their homes energy
costs are driving up the cost of
everything else in the economy
but for years now
our ideologically insane ruling class
has argued in their occasional moments
of honesty that it's actually a good
thing that this is actually precisely
the sort of thing that we're rooting for
under my plan
of a cap and trade system
electricity rates would necessarily
skyrocket so could these prices help us
i think that
i would have preferred a gradual
adjustment in 2008 you supported ramping
up
gas prices somehow we have to figure out
how to boost the price of gasoline to
the levels in europe where it is now
more than ten dollars a gallon that that
last clip was obama's energy secretary
before that it was obama himself saying
yeah we want higher prices that's what
we're looking for what we are living
through right now is precisely the sort
of thing that our rulers have been
calling for for over a decade
these are the people planning our future
these are the people building our future
they're not even hiding it
and if they are permitted to keep the
control that they've got the future is
going to look pretty bleak i'm michael
knowles this is the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from the drummer's
workshop at norm's workshop who says i
guess whoopi goldberg wanted to ver to
divert our attention away from asking
what is a woman to what is an archbishop
that's true they don't know they don't
know much about anything these days well
what really is
an archbishop an archbishop is uh the
leader of uh
is pelosi's shepherd that's who it is no
that that bishop doesn't have any right
no that's what an archbishop is a woman
has no right to the women's room no
that's what a woman is that's guys this
is basic stuff we figured it out okay
the mistake that the critics of our
ruling class are making right now when
they look at all the terrible stuff
going on in the country and around the
world
is they think this is an accident
it's not an accident
the negative effects on the polls might
be accidental the criticism that the
administration is getting might be
accidental but the actual stuff driving
up the cost of energy opening up the
border flooding the country with
immigrants and illegal aliens the
disorder we're seeing elsewhere around
the world and the fraying world or all
this stuff
is the point it is the plan they've been
telling us this for over a decade we
should have listened we should have paid
attention some of us did and so you're
not surprised when you see this happen
now that's what the world economic forum
is about the world economic forum which
is going on in davos switzerland
is a
cartoonish
gathering of world leaders lots and lots
of heads of state lots and lots of
corporate leaders all meeting up in this
non-governmental body this just kind of
non-profit this strange little meeting
they all go to and they tell you
verbatim we are the ones planning the
future
let's
also be clear
the future is not just happening
the future is built by us
by a powerful community as
you here in this group
we have some means
to improve the states of the world
but two conditions are necessary
the first one
is
that we act all
as stakeholders
of larger communities
that we serve not our only
self-interests that we serve the
community
that's what we call stakeholder
responsibility
and second that we collaborate
and this is the reason why you find
many opportunities here during the
meeting
to engage
into very action and impact-oriented
initiatives
to make
progress
related to specific issues on the global
agenda
if the screen behind klaus schwab there
the head of the world economic forum if
the screen did not say world economic
forum if instead it said spectre
i would not bat an eyelash
if this were not taking place on the
news but taking place in the next james
bond movie i would not be surprised at
all the language is that cartoonishly
villainous the future does not just
happen
no mr bond the future is being built by
us
we are the ones who will build the
future if we collaborate together
collaborate together by the way what
people say that when you criticize the
world economic forum you're engaging in
a crazy conspiracy theory
clash fob just said it's a conspiracy
that's what conspiracy is is when people
with outsized influence and power get
together and collaborate
largely behind closed doors in secret
locations in the middle of switzerland
this is the plot of a bond movie this is
what they are doing and it's not just
the government leaders and it's not just
the corporate leaders and it's not just
the ngo leaders the humanitarian types
who who project the power of liberal
empire
it's all of them together it's all of
them together working behind the scenes
why do they have to do this in davos
switzerland because they know that you
won't like it that's why they're not
debating this stuff in the u.s congress
that's why they're not debating this
stuff in the parliaments of europe
because then it would be open to the
the input of the people and they know
that the people don't like any of this
stuff they know that the people are
never going to vote for higher gas
prices
if it's put to them in those plain terms
if that's really what they know is on
the ballot people aren't going to vote
for it but these are the ones building
the future and they know what is better
and so if we are going to transition
then we need to raise the prices of the
energy
and build the future against the feel of
their people
i'm not thankfully i'm not going into my
outright german
it sounds even scarier in the original
german so that's what's happening at the
world economic forum that's what they're
telling us is happening this is not
being put into a public stage or up for
a public vote but there are clips that
come out of the world economic forum
like this one
uh
someone at the world economic forum the
president of alibaba group which is a
chinese company j michael evans boasted
at the world economic forum that he was
going to develop an individual carbon
footprint tracker to monitor the
terrible effect that you the ordinary
person
have on the world
we're developing
through technology an ability for
consumers to measure their own carbon
footprint
what does that mean that's
where are they traveling how are they
traveling what are they eating what are
they consuming on the platform
so individual carbon footprint tracker
stay tuned we don't have it operational
yet but this is something that we're
working on
isn't this a great idea
you know the one thing that makes me
feel a little bit better about the world
economic forum and all these
liberal lunatics meeting together and
conspiring to take over the world the
one thing that makes me feel better is
that they are fairly incompetent so a
lot of what you hear at the world
economic forum is hey i've got this
great idea and we haven't actually built
it or anything but it's going to be
really great it doesn't sound great to
me i don't like that that doesn't sound
good to me
that this
guy who runs a dodgy company is
developing a tracker to to track your
essentially your social credit score and
to determine what what degree of secular
sin you have committed because you you
ate a bag of potato chips on a train
platform
and you figure out how many lashings you
deserve because of your sins against
mother gaia and the environment that
doesn't sound like a beautiful idea to
me it does sound like a beautiful idea
to the people in that room because they
are disordered and perverted and they
are letting their liberal ideological
utopian dreams run away with them
but the irony of course here is that the
people who show up to the world economic
forum
produce more waste produce more air
pollution send more carbon into the
atmosphere than anyone else on earth
how many people at the world economic
forum flew private jets to land there
if not most of them
a whole lot of them that's how many
heads of state heads of private
companies they all fly they spend more
more pollution they expend more
pollution and more carbon in one hour
than you probably do in your entire year
and then they lecture you and say you've
really got to cut that out we don't need
to cut it out because we're special
because we are planning the future we
are much more important but but you you
do have to cut it out
that is the kind of thinking that takes
place here
so funny that it was the alibaba group
president too because china of course
emits more greenhouse gas into the
atmosphere than the entire developed
world combined but that's okay it's
separate rules you don't understand we
are building the future we are building
the new order and if it doesn't make
sense to yourself too bad this is a
transition we have to crack some eggs to
make it hamlets ah i'm claustrophobic
that's what they're saying i think we
need to hire new rulers when you want to
hire new people you got to check out
ziprecruiter right now go to
ziprecruiter.com
knowles certain people in my life make
my life so much easier i couldn't get
along without them i think first and
foremost of my wife my wife but then you
know people at work my assistant
my producers
and when you want these people in your
life well first of all back off my wife
buddy you're not getting my wife okay
and you better not hire away my staff
either but you can
hire your own people and the way to do
it is with a zip recruiter that's right
go to zip recruiter they are the number
one way to get people for your company
this is the most important investment
you can possibly make
is in your staff and you can try zip
recruiter for free at ziprecruiter.com
knowles
personnel is policy okay that is how
your company is going to work is
contingent on
who you hire and who is actually putting
your policies into effect okay the
hardest thing you're going to have to
remember about any of this is just the
url ziprecruiter.com
knowles that's where you go to try
ziprecruiter for free that is
ziprecruiter.com canadawles ziprecruiter
the smartest way to hire
another one of these self-appointed
benevolent bettors at the world economic
forum this this time a lady from
australia the e-safety commissioner
pointed out at the world economic forum
that we need to recalibrate the way we
think about free speech
we are finding ourselves in a place um
where we're we have increasing
polarization everywhere
and everything feels binary when it
doesn't need to be so i think we're
going to have to think about a
recalibration of a whole range of human
rights that are playing out online you
know from freedom of speech to the
freedom to
you know to be free from online violence
or the right of data protection to the
right to child dignity
we just need to recalibrate the speech
this clip went viral yesterday a lot of
conservatives furious about it
the woman is obviously wrong in practice
can you even imagine what it would mean
if she were in control of recalibrating
free speech it would it would basically
just mean the conservatives are not
allowed to speak and the liberals are
allowed to speak that's what every
single person at the world economic
forum wants that's what every
liberal elite
flitting about on their private jets
that's what all of them want
however she is right in principle
she is i know that's going to be an
unpopular thing to say among
conservatives but it's true i wrote a
whole book about this called speechless
controlling words controlling minds
there are always limits on speech there
there are limits right now there have
been limits throughout the history of
our country there have been actually in
the past in some ways many more limits
than there are today there have been
limits on speech throughout the whole
history of civilization that's because
certain speech is off limits fraud
direct threats fighting words obscenity
we still have laws against obscenity
even though they're not enforced as much
anymore there we've had blasphemy laws
in this country for goodness sakes now
that seems unthinkable well we actually
do still have blasphemy laws in a way
it's just not it's they're not laws that
prohibit blaspheming god they're laws
that prohibit blaspheming
the pride flag or
or the blm or there are there are all of
these rules if not outright laws federal
laws state laws at least regulations
rules within corporate life within the
schools within community life that will
within the big tech platforms that will
prohibit you from saying those things so
there are always going to be limits i
think in principle she's totally right i
do think we need to recalibrate free
speech right now the current speech
regime in the west is punitive against
conservatives
and lets libs do things that they should
not be permitted to do
and engage in kind of speech and
sometimes defenses of violence that they
and calls to violence that they should
not be permitted to do just to look at
what what was permitted during the blm
riots
so i think we need to recalibrate she's
right let's recalibrate it and let's
put some more limits on what the libs
are doing and the calls to violence and
the disorder in our society and let's
open up speech again a little bit for
the conservatives i guess that's what
elon musk is trying to do at twitter
there is pushback against this stuff
do you know why people
concoct all sorts of theories about the
world economic forum well in part
because a lot of them are true in the
world economic forum is telling us this
but in part it's because people look at
these clips they hear what the liberal
elites from around the world want to do
their utopian vision for society and the
people don't like it
they don't like and they say hey
whatever you're doing stop it
we don't want that
and the wef knows that we don't want
that that's why they've got to
save all their craziest ideas for this
meeting in switzerland
that is where the messaging is largely
controlled
where where when a conservative
journalist shows up my friend jack
bosovic showed up there he was briefly
detained by the world economic forum
police
and then then
he started broadcasting it or other
people are started broadcasting and all
of a sudden they they let him go
but the world economic forum tightly
controls this kind of messaging and they
know that the people don't like what
they're talking about just look what
happened at state farm state farm the
insurance company
sent out an email a few days ago
subject gender curriculum
this is to florida agents here seeking
agent support for the gender cool
project a state farm is partnering with
the gender cool project to help
diversify classroom community center and
library bookshelves with a collection of
books to help bring clarity and
understanding to the national
conversation about being transgender
inclusive and non-binary the project's
goal is to increase representation of
lgbtq plus books and support our
communities and having challenging
important and empowering conversations
with children age five and up
age five and up so this this email came
to light a few days ago was actually
sent january 18th of this year
it was only leaked a few days ago
because even some
people who work at state farm said this
is insane state farm the insurance
company for some reason state farm is
now trying to trans the kids so they
leak the email
and then what happens
does state farm double down
does state forum pull at disney and say
no we're going to go even we're going to
trans the four year olds now we're going
to trans to three-year-olds how dare you
little people
push back against this we're inclusive
and diverse and equitable and we're
going to try to trans the little babies
in your womb did they say that no
no they did the opposite of what disney
did they sent an email
within a day or two of of this earlier
email being leaked subject gender
curriculum
from victor terry the chief diversity
offer officer of state farm state farm
support of a philanthropic program
genderqueer has been the subject of news
and customer inquiries this program that
included books about gender identity was
intended to promote inclusivity
conversations about gender identity
should happen at home with parents we
don't support required curriculum in
schools on this topic we support
organizations providing resources for
parents to have these conversations we
will no longer support that program
but you know we'll keep pushing
diversity and inclusion so almost
a complete surrender here they gave
themselves wiggle room so we should keep
pushing on state farm they gave
themselves we don't want it to be
mandatory in the classroom but maybe
they'll put these resources in the
elementary school libraries well we got
to stop that too keep pushing keep
pushing harder but this is evidence
companies learned their lesson from
disney
some people are calling it the disney
effect
and what was the disney effect
a woke corporation tried to push these
radical sex theories on little kids they
expected conservatives to roll over like
we always do
florida republicans led by ron desantis
say no we're not going to do that we're
actually going to punish you disney
we're going to take away your tax
benefits we're going to take away all
the special deals you've got with the
florida legislature we're going to
vilify you in the media well we're not
vilifying you you have vilified
yourselves by doing villainous things
we're going to expose that in the media
and we are not going to let up for one
freaking second you weirdos because the
people are beh not only because it's the
right thing to do but because the people
are behind us and you are going to lose
this battle if we can have it fair and
square in the public square
and guess what happened
they won and disney lost
and that was a great win for the kids of
florida and it was a great victory over
disney
almost more importantly it sent a
message to the state farms of the world
it sent a message to all the other
companies and all the other sectors
f around and find out
that was the message that seems to be a
major theme this year in the news
with all of the you hear it from the
white house and now you're hearing it
from the conservatives try me
i dare you
bring it up and what happens
we won there too keep pushing keep
pushing even harder state farm didn't
cave out of the goodness of their heart
or because they've seen
the the light of the moral order i don't
think that's what's behind it i think
they realized that they were going to
have a big big business problem
if their secret little plan to trans the
kids
continued after it was exposed to public
light
this is what's going on and this is the
big fight this is what's going on in the
schools
the reason that the parents movement is
taking place right now is because
radical lessons that had previously been
taught secretly in classrooms are now
being taught or are now coming to light
in large part because parents got to see
what their kids were learning when it
was being beamed into their homes on a
computer screen for the past two years
but sunlight is a great disinfectant
this is why
the world economic forum is the target
of such a ire now
the liberal elites thought they were
having their private meeting in the
little private place in switzerland
clips are leaking around the world
people don't like what they see and so
they're pushing back there's a new
racial literacy curriculum that's being
taught in lots of schools
that is turning
every subject woke
this is being pushed by pollyanna
incorporated
it's for high school students but it's
not just
teaching them
radicalism class it's not just teaching
them okay you've got you've got math
you've got history you've got literature
and you've got social justice
math history literature and progressive
politics no
it's much subtler and and more powerful
than that what these curricula do is
inject wokeness and leftism into every
single subject obviously history we've
been dealing with that for decades
obviously literature we've also been
dealing with that for decades
obviously
sex ed or you know i mean that
comprehensive sex ed is just teaching a
kind of liberal sexual ethic in the
schools that's always been the case
not even just science and but
math too
because of a leaked implementation
seminar don't forget this was all
happening behind the scenes
the libs who were pushing this stuff
were trying to hide it from you because
they know that you the parents won't
like it very much but part of one of
their seminars was just leaked because
it was occurring online and it showed
that the libs are now wokening
math class
do not can you hear that can you hear
what's going on
well if you can't hear then you've
absolutely got to go check out md
hearing aid right now go to
mdhearing.com use promo code knowles did
you know that 9 out of 10 people still
buy hearing aids from clinics and pay 5
000
or more even though much more affordable
options exist that's why you've got to
check out md hearing aid md hearing aid
is an fda registered rechargeable
hearing aid that costs a fraction of
what typical hearing aids cost md
hearing aids volt plus model costs over
eighty percent eight zero less than
clinic hearing aids they bring clinic
level care right to you via telemedicine
from doctors and licensed hearing
professionals md hearing aid was founded
by an ent surgeon who saw how many of
his patients needed hearing aids but
couldn't afford them he made it his
mission to develop a quality hearing aid
that anyone could afford if you forget
to take your hearing aids off in the
shower do not worry the volt plus is
water resistant and up to three feet of
water rechargeable with battery life
that lasts up to 30 hours
i
really really love this company
a family member of mine refused to get
hearing aids even though she should have
years ago because of this cost and it
really reduced her quality of life make
sure you go avail yourself of this
opportunity right now get clinic level
care for 80 less with md hearing aid go
to mdhearing.com use promo code knowles
to get their new buy one get 149.99 each
when you buy a pair deal they are adding
a free extra charging case that's a 100
value just for our listeners so head on
over to mdhearing.com
use promo code knowles get their new buy
one get 149.99 each when you buy a pair
deal
also we have got right when you thought
that the media and the global fear
agents were finally running out of
material we've got a whole new pandemic
that just dropped that would be the
monkey pox pandemic now listen call me
crazy but with any new outbreak i would
like to get a first a clear sense about
the risk before i go into full scale
panic mode and sprint toward my nearest
17 jab provider so i can just stick
myself on a vaccine iv like the libs
want me to i want to get the facts well
good news is candace is getting the
facts right now she's sitting down with
dr robert malone he made his return to
candace last night a really really great
interview you remember dr malone from
his interview with joe rogan his
speeches against the covid shots well
he's sitting down he's providing science
he's providing facts he's providing data
you can watch last night's exclusive
interview by becoming a daily wire
member at dailywire.com subscribe get 25
off your new membership that's
dailywire.com
subscribe
we'll be right back with a lot more
when you're in math class when i was in
math class
i learned two plus two equals four
i learned
three times three equals nine
sometimes we go beyond that we do word
problems if john leaves st louis going
55 miles an hour and sally leaves
chicago going 26 miles an hour that kind
of
now what the woke left has done is gone
into even math classes and transformed
even the math curriculum
to push a radical leftist agenda here is
the plan from pollyanna incorporated
so students learn about daca or the
deferred action for childhood arrivals
pro
which currently supports over seven
hundred thousand people brought to the
united states as children of
adaptation and so in the first part of
this lesson um students explore the
impacts
of both both individually and on our
broader society of the july 2021 court
ruling that daca was
unconstitutional and then in the second
part of the lesson students imagine that
they are helping to plan a protest in
support of daca and they need to
determine how to maximize attendance
given a variety of outreach options and
constraints
this is this is going to help students
think about math you see if if pablo
pays the criminal cartel 10 000
to smuggle him and his friends into the
united states and juan sells his sister
into slavery to the cartel so that he
can get a ride across the rio grande
what is the number of their criminal
gang
ms 13. there it is didn't you just learn
something about math was it that's great
now you're prepared to be become an
engineer someday aren't you aren't you
so glad that the libs woke the math
curriculum not just on daca so they they
transform the math curriculum to to suit
their goals on the immigration policy
then they use the math curriculum to
push a completely false narrative that
cops in the united states have an
epidemic problem of targeting innocent
black men and then lesson eight um
this is a heavy one and we definitely
recommend that teachers prepare their
students and themselves um in advance of
teaching this lesson it's about police
killings of people of color and it uses
data to explore racial
disproportionality among the victims of
police killings and of police use of
force
so students examine real world data to
determine that black and latinx people
are killed by police at rates
proportionate to their overall
representation in the u.s population
and then they examine data that debunk
the misperception that police kill more
black and latinx people because those
people commit more crimes
and then finally they consider what it
would take to eliminate these
disparities
so there are two problems with this
approach to education at least there's
probably more than two problems but the
two major problems are one
the the woke teachers and the people
creating the world curricula are filling
students heads with things that are not
true
they're filling students heads with a an
understanding of american history and
literature and
and
society and politics that is not true
and they do it in every single class
including math that's the first thing
but the second thing that's so awful
about this strategy
is
they are depriving kids of an actual
education
two kids go to math class one goes to
ordinary math class and learns
arithmetic and algebra and trigonometry
and calculus and then another kid goes
to
this woke math class where they learn
that george floyd is a secular saint and
cops are really bad and we need to
abolish the police and also two plus two
equals four which kid regardless of all
the stupid political ideology coming
into the second kid's head which kid is
going to get the better math education
obviously the former
so these libs are like absolute leeches
they're just absolute parasites not only
infecting their host with diseases but
also just sucking them dry depriving
them of nutrients that they otherwise
would get in their education
this is happening in the shadows because
every reasonable person hates it and
objects to it i don't care what part of
the country you're in what race you are
what background you come from whether
you're a republican or a democrat
obviously all the republicans are going
to hate this stuff but i bet most of the
democrats are going to hate it too
this is radical stuff the evidence of it
of how unpopular it is is that they have
to teach it in the shadows
speaking of math and kids
it's it's not only the ordinary people
who are pushing back against the
prevailing orthodoxies of the libs it's
some of the elite people as well elon
musk is really good at least on this one
point
of math and kids he's really good at
counteracting the prevailing liberal
view
of
kids and births and the population
the libs believe that there are too many
people
notice they never believe that they are
one of the too many people they they
never offer to go away okay we have
overpopulation you know what i'll just
call it a day right now and take a long
walk off a short cliff they never do
that it's always it's always your kid
it's always your grandkid that's the one
that needs to go away not them
musk says no we don't have an
overpopulation problem we have a serious
underpopulation problem he pointed out
yesterday usa birth rate has been below
minimum sustainable levels for around 50
years contrary to what many people think
the richer someone is the fewer kids
they have i am a rare exception because
elon has a lot of kids
most people i know have zero or one kid
and this is true according to statista
in 2017 the birth rate in the u.s was
highest in families that had under 10
000 in income per year that was 66.44
births per thousand women
as income scale increases the birth rate
decreases families making 200 grand or
more per year
have the lowest birth rate
so people who are in abject poverty
have the highest birth rate
people making a ton of money 200 grand
or more per year have the absolute
lowest birth rate
there's a similar point here actually on
abortion very often you will hear that
abortion is so important to poor women
that abortion is a way to help poor
women and the
the philosophy behind that is really
sick that basically we just need to kill
the poor because we don't want to take
care of them but the numbers are wrong
too they probably learned woke pollyanna
math and that's why they don't get their
numbers right yes it is true
that
more poor women get abortions than rich
women do but that's only because there
are more poor women than there are rich
women just as a matter of the population
if you look at the rates of abortion if
you look at the likelihood that a poor
woman is going to get an abortion
compared to a rich woman getting an
abortion you'll find out that rich women
are three times more than three times as
likely to get an abortion as poor women
are
if you look this was actually published
by vox.com this is published by a a
liberal
a liberal outlet a liberal explainer
outlet they've got figure four here on
their on their article abortion rates by
income group if you're
below the poverty line
if you're you're in the the bottom fifth
year of this graph
you've got
almost the the lowest rate of abortion
basically tied for the lowest rate of
abortion and then you go to 400 percent
plus of the poverty rate
it's more than three times that number
you can't you can't just blame it on
poverty you can't just blame it on
the the unfairness of the system and
people can't afford to get ahead no this
is
much much deeper than that
speaking of kids obviously we have to
get to the horrific story that happened
yesterday
i'm sure you know what happened already
but
an 18 year old gunman opened fire
yesterday to texas elementary school
he killed
at le last time i checked it was 19
children it may be more now and i
believe two adults as well finally the
attacker was killed by law enforcement
the hideousness the horror of the crime
speaks for itself
my only hot take on this
i don't have a hot take
that's my hot take my hot take is i
don't have a hot take my hot take is
the reflexive political posturing
that that happened
within minutes of this news breaking
is so
revolting
that i just refuse to engage in it
and it and it plays out in the
predictable way that happens every time
there is a shooting event if the shooter
is
white it's all about white supremacy if
the shooter is not white as in this case
it's all about gun control and you have
all the usual suspects immediately
rehearsing their same points their same
either sincere or more frequently
feigned outrage about the lack of gun
control policies in this country they
never propose anything in particular
because none of the policies that they
have proposed would have stopped any of
these shootings
historically speaking obviously more
facts will come out about this one but
that's been the case in all of the other
ones and then they they become very
indignant and self-righteous and they
say how dare you offer thoughts and
prayers how dare you suggest that we
take a moment and pray because of this
horrible tragedy and they they
themselves don't offer anything else
and then maybe some of them the more
radical of them will say
well we just need to get rid of the
second amendment if that's the
impediment we need to get rid of the
second amendment and even if one were to
think that that was a good idea i don't
think that's a good idea but even if one
were to think that's a good idea
it's not practicable at all it would
start a civil war so they're not they're
not offering any solutions they're just
they're just jumping up and down
on
at the at the very moment of a tragedy
of a really unthinkable tragedy
to push their same old tired political
agenda and you'll see it a little bit to
conservatives then will become very very
uh reflexively defensive and they'll
look in and say well was this guy an
illegal alien or was parents illegal
aliens or was it an illegal gun and
they'll they'll try to get all of the
facts to score their political points
too obviously in much less so in a much
more defensive posture than you're
seeing from the left but the whole thing
is just so sickening it's so absolutely
repulsive
that i would just suggest
you don't need a take you don't need to
take
you don't you don't
and everyone talks about thoughts and
prayers
and and on the left they dismiss
thoughts and prayers they themselves
offer their own thoughts immediately
they never stop offering their own
thoughts or whatever whatever even
resembles a thought to them
no prayer is just just
i would i would recommend just just
prayer prayer is pretty good it's the
most efficacious thing that anyone is
suggesting
it is the
it is the
classy thing to do it is the
civilized thing to do
you don't need to jump the very second
that an a really unthinkable haunting
tragedy occurs you don't need to jump
that very second to push your political
agenda or frankly even to push back
against someone else's political agenda
or to find all the statistics or to find
all the right facts and to say boom c
owned debunked got it you don't have to
it is so
classless
it is so
inhuman
it is so uncivilized
bad things can just happen
and you can just
feel sad about that and you can just
pray
because none of your none of your
posturing
you know you you might observe that none
of none of the posturing the proposals
that come out would have stopped this
that can be debated later on what is
certain is none of your posturing is
going to bring
the dead kids back it's not going to do
that
the only thing you can do is pray
that could even possibly have any effect
so maybe just do that maybe that's fine
it's so
i i almost can't look at twitter right
now
i almost can't look because and it's not
it is being driven by the left it's not
it's not only the left but it obviously
is being it being driven by the left and
it's so
crass and vulgar and so
disgusting
just don't have to do it this is common
sense this would have been considered
common sense common courtesy common
class
not that long ago
but we've lost all sense of that all
sense of decorum
maybe people weren't raised right maybe
they just don't get raised right anymore
i guess that ties into the education
issue people aren't really raised right
have some class have some manners have
some common sense common sense i mean
this this is
to to bring it back to the broader
political issues we're talking about
here
that that is what we are seeing reassert
itself when we're talking about
education when we're talking about the
transgender issue when we're talking
about
when we're talking about gas prices when
we're talking about the crazy liberal
schemes of the world economic forum
the pushback it's not
totally 100
republican versus democrat left versus
right conservative versus leftist
it is
in many ways
liberal utopians versus people with a
modicum of common sense
who maybe would have called themselves
democrats even three years ago
but don't want their kids to get trans
or don't want
critical race theory being taught in
their schools this is this is why the
comedians are having a field day right
now ricky gervais has a comedy special
coming out
part of it has leaked and in it he goes
on
a very funny rant against transgender
ideology
the old-fashioned women oh god you know
the ones with wombs
those dinosaurs
no i love the the new whip i know
they're new i mean they're great aren't
they you know the new ones we've been
seeing lately there were the ones with
beards and they're as good as
they're as good as gold i love them
now it's the old fashioned way and now
the old fashioned they're like oh they
want to use our toilets why shouldn't
they use your toilets for ladies
they are ladies look at their pronouns
what about this person isn't a lady well
his penis
her penis you figured
what if he raped me
what if she raped you
try not laughing at that try not
laughing you can't not laugh because the
reason that you're laughing is because
the reality is so absurd
that even the comedians ricky gervais
dave chappelle dave chappelle's not a
conservative all of these guys are
making jokes about it and all the funny
memes on the internet right by the way
it's not just the well-established
professional comedians
it's the memes it's all the all the
actual comedy culture that's going on
right now is all making fun of this
stuff
and it's because
people just know it's because people
still have common sense even if our
genius rulers whether they're in davos
or unfortunately if some of them are
back here in the u.s if they don't know
it
that's their problem the people still
have some common sense
political correctness in entertainment
is really really annoying
we all know that i am glad to see that
the disney effect is having a lot of
effect netflix here netflix did kind of
back dave chappelle when he got in
trouble for telling politically
incorrect jokes
netflix is saying we're not going to
reign in our creators
state farm is saying we're not going to
trans the kids anymore
but it's creeping in and it's really
annoying it has largely destroyed
professional sports i never really cared
about the nba or the nfl but the blm
movement went in and really wrecked
those sports
the one holdout in professional sports
had been baseball
because baseball is just a little more
conservative it's america's oldest
favorite pastime it
while all the other sports have
descended into political madness
baseball they usually just keep their
heads down and keep playing the game and
that's that's great but there there was
another one of these woke incidents that
unfortunately took place in baseball mlb
just suspended the yankees third baseman
josh donaldson over what they call quote
inappropriate comments toward the white
star white sox shortstop
tim anderson here is tim describing the
great terrible offense
yeah he just made a you know
disrespectful coming
uh you know baseball is you know trying
to call me jackie robinson's like what's
up jackie
you know
i don't play like that you know
i don't really play at all um
you know i wasn't i wasn't really you
know bothering nobody today but uh you
know he made comment and you know it was
disrespectful and uh i don't think it
was called foreign
yeah but that happened in the first the
first time they got home you know when i
spared them that time
then it happened again
um and you know it was just you know
it's just uncalled for you know it's not
like i got time to you know be playing
like that
okay so he's upset because
josh donaldson called him
jackie robinson first of all what is
offensive about that
i would be honored to be called jackie
robinson jackie robinson was a great and
important baseball player
that seems like a nice thing to be
called
why no that's very offensive okay well
why did he call you jackie robinson was
it in some way was he making some insult
because you're black was that is that
why he's comparing you to jackie
robinson uh oh wait hold on uh tim
anderson has the same number as jackie
robinson
both number 42.
okay so maybe it wasn't
it was it definitely wasn't an insult
maybe it wasn't a racial thing it might
have to do with the fact that you both
have the same number and oh yeah you tim
anderson have regularly compared
yourself to jackie robinson and have
made lots of videos and lots of comments
to the media calling yourself today's
jackie robinson and say that you like
jackie robinson are completely changing
the game of baseball this is how you
style yourself
this would be like
you you give yourself a nickname
you you out there in
podcast radio land you give yourself a
nickname and then you tell everyone
that's your new nickname and then
somebody calls you that nickname and you
say you're a racist
you're you that's an offensive comment
what you mean it's an offensive comment
it's what you told me to call you
that's no no you're not allowed to do
that now what what is this really about
what this is really about is tim
anderson doesn't like josh donaldson i
guess there's some bad blood between
these two players and so anderson
decided to get back at donaldson and the
easiest way to get back at someone at
all today is to call him a racist
because being called a racist is the
worst thing that you can possibly be
called
and that and that that worked the white
sox manager
tony larussa
called donaldson a racist he said he
made a racist comment donaldson and
that's all i'm going to say that's as
strong as it gets he didn't make a
racist comment he made a perfectly
innocuous comment he basically just
quoted
what tim anderson himself had said about
himself
and it was a flattering statement
but that's the worst thing you can be
called as a racist and and
so this guy to get back at
donaldson for whatever slight whatever
bad blood they had between them called
him a racist this is often what happens
drew clavin makes this point
very often when people if people attack
you for being
for your race
for your sex
for your sexual behaviors for whatever
forever whatever aspect about you
these days
that is interpreted by everybody as
meaning that the person who per person
who says the remarks is a racist is a
sexist is a this phobe is a that phobe
but that's not true that's not actually
how insults work
that's not how men interact with each
other
9 times out of 10 99 times out of 100
what that proves is
that person who said it just doesn't
like the guy that he said it to and so
he's looking for any way to attack that
guy and he will attack that guy in the
easiest way possible if i walk up to if
i walk up to our
giant
scary assistant director here on this
show powell and i say hey listen here
you poll pollock well i would never say
that because i'd probably be put through
a wall and there'd be a michael-shaped
hole in the wall within two seconds but
if i if i said that i said hey you
pollock does that does that mean that i
don't like polish people no it would
just mean that i'm angry at pavel and
the first thing that comes to mind about
him is that he's polish and so i'd say
that to him
and and frankly that's what tim anderson
is doing here to josh donaldson i don't
think that tim anderson thinks that josh
donaldson is a racist i think he doesn't
like josh donaldson and so the first
thing he's going to is the easiest way
to attack him you're a racist
it's so petty it's so ugly it's so
dishonest
and it bugs me in particular i'm not a
huge sports guy but i do love major
league baseball and the yankees in
particular and so it does bug me when i
think this last redoubt of civility of
manners of pro of playing the game the
other issue i have with tim anderson is
he's a big showboater and he makes a big
deal and he flicks his bat and he dances
around and he he is upsetting the norms
of the game unlike other sports in
baseball generally speaking people just
do their job and they play and they're
humble and they hit the home run and
they run they run the base they don't
stand there and wait and dance around
they run and they keep their head down
and they play the game and that's what i
think a lot of people are longing for
it's it's why the baseball thing is
hitting me hard in particular but that's
what we're talking about in the schools
that's what we're talking about in our
norms when we talk about respect for
institutions the way we comport
ourselves in in the public square the
way we talk on social media what people
are longing for is a return to something
resembling the old standards the norms
okay that we got to recalibrate things
to to quote the lady at the world
economic forum we do have to recalibrate
things because the effect of our of the
social revolution cultural revolution
we've seen for the last half century or
more is not merely that our rights are
changing and the laws and the rules but
it's it's the whole norm it's the whole
whole culture it's the standard it's the
way that we behave with one another what
we come to expect
we're not allowed to have norms anymore
we're not allowed to say that anything
is normal we actually have to say that
abnormal things are the normal things
and the normal things are evil and
abnormal and that and that's what people
are reacting against that builds a big
coalition if you just ran on the hey hey
everybody be normal and good platform
you would win 50 states i'm michael
knowles the michael knowles show see you
tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2022. on
the matt wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture faith current
events all the fundamentals if they
matter to you come check out the show